hi Miley congratulations on being the
new Viva Glam spokesmodel thank you I
want to talk to you about your
generation and their relationship to you
know AIDS and HIV when I grew up it's
something that at school you know we
were very aware of we were you know
there were classes and we're taught
about it but I feel it's how do you feel
it's different now my mom about it how
she said you know there was such a
paranoia when she was younger because no
one knew what this epidemic was it was
taking over kind of the world and so
quickly and so many people's live so she
was saying there was you know kind of
such a moment of panic and that she was
so aware and then like everything you
know it kind of wants a panic dies down
I think people forget of how important
it is for you know kids to be educated
for people to be you know making sure
they're they're taking care of
themselves and checking themselves and
bringing awareness and also supporting
the people that their lives are being
affected by it every single day and I
think it's important for me is someone
that talked to so many young people all
the time being able to take advantage of
the platform that I've been given that's
why I Mac is so cool because they they
do the same thing it's so easy when you
have everything to not want to give back
in this way but Mac just using their
power for good versus kind of doing
nothing with it and and so it was
important for me to get involved with
them and when I first saw it I thought
oh wow that's like really I mean that's
like a really really poppy say it was
you didn't put it on like either way it
doesn't have to be so oh yeah Amir well
girl go see but it's not that it's like
crazy talk about 10 million Li so you
put on the lip gloss but that's just me
but I did the lipsticks or like older
girls can wear but then the younger
girls can just do the gloss or you can
do the gloss if you're going out like
day I think it's good to do that and
then it's
okay yeah and it feels it does feel good
but that does it's nice and creamy
remember when I first saw the shade it's
what you said it's like the creamy that
was my obsession where I kept getting
like samples of try and I was like it
has to feel like more like like the way
young lips feel I'm like cuz I kept
trying my little sister was my guinea
pig and then I would be the tester for
you know my kind of age but I was like I
just want it to not feel I want to feel
like it's feels kind of natural and good
but I also think you know it's a shade
that to me when I first saw it I thought
it was something that you know your
godmother dolly parton could wear there
it's a very kind of so I think it's a
color for like everyone not just I think
is mine pink is my signature color so
visit don't mean your ad as well it's
really stunning and it's all like bright
and pink and how much fun was it making
that shooting that I was that was
another thing that I was really
obsessive about was the creative of that
because when I made the gloss I thought
I was like I want it to basically be if
the lipstick got melted down and then
somebody melted 10-billion disco balls
and do it what it would be I wanted to
feel like disco pink lips and almost
like I wanted to have kind of like a
cyber vibe so that's why I kind of has a
little bit of the kind of like metallic
you feel to it you you know I was very
supportive your own perfume like
everybody has their perfume why don't
you have your why don't you have your
own perfume - iris only because I think
when you start getting involved with too
many big companies and corporations they
all of a sudden tried it on in your life
and I just don't want anyone to own my
life but me so I don't have to answer to
anybody that's the truth and Mac with
the freedom that they have they would
never ask me to do that so that's why I
wanted to do it they're like celebrating
who people actually are not trying to
suppress
to be a certain way like when you're
just because you do something for
somebody if you do a perfume or whatever
you do you shouldn't be responsible for
an entire company should only ever be
responsible for your own life so you
know this kind of is the best thing for
me because it's just about doing what my
focus was this year which was kind of
getting more involved and doing things
that actually matter rather than just
selling any lipstick you just come
across as someone really fearless to me
but do you have moments where you just
like think oh I yeah we have like a
little confidence it's kind of like most
people here the loan we oh god I don't
feel confident today and what do you do
- oh you tie my thigh drives my mom
crazy like even before cos you look at
photos of herself she said I did it my
whole life she said the whole town was
in my 20s like I just felt like I was so
not beautiful all of a sudden she goes
now I look at photos of myself and I
love it so much it's like so now I
celebrate Who I am now because we all do
it and then we always look at pictures
of us back in the past that we loved it
but at that time we put so much pressure
women have so much pressure it is so
insane the amount of pressure we're
putting in for the very beginning down
like physically emotionally the way that
we feel for other people like are it's
hard for us to not feel other people's
pain it's like just being a woman can be
so hard so adding more stress on
yourself we do it so much we overthink
everything so I definitely have moments
where like I freaked out like today how
I was freaking out about this huge
pimple right now you're on micro size
but it was a lot worse last night and
you know put on the zit cream before I
went to sleep but it's that's kind of
when I get into it's always had bad skin
growing up so I just kind of all always
still even if no one else notices I feel
like everyone's always looking at it but
that's just
thank you very much yeah